perché abbiamo avuto dei relatori
estremamente qualificati che hanno
tenuto sù il morale e l'attenzione
solitamente i ore detto che è il momento
di dare un braille light una un lavaggio
di luce forte a tutti voi perché magari
siete affaticati e stanchi sì perché la
luce incide fortemente nello stato
d'animo delle persone nel benessere
delle persone e voglio partire proprio
da ciò che abbiamo cercato di fare e
stiamo cercando di fare come impresa
eravamo già nel settore
dell'illuminazione della d'arredo dal 59
al 75 crisi del petrolio girando il
mondo
avevo capito che il settore del design
del decorativo seppur importante aveva
una soglia d'ingresso molto bassa e ho
visto come si poteva cambiare il modo di
vivere gli ambienti all'esterno
all'esterno cambiando prodotto cambiando
cultura cambiando approccio e pertanto
passare dalla rampa oggetto alla regia
luminosa degli spazi perché con la
ricerca windows e si riusciva a creare
gli ambienti giusti al momento giusto
negli spazi giusti per tanto per
cambiare così fortemente la fortuna di
impresa e ovvio che abbiamo avuto
bisogno di nuovi collaboratori di
persone di grande cultura di grande
esperienza per acculturare la nostra
impresa ma già chi all'epoca aveva
responsabilità di guidare l'impresa
aveva questo sentimento aveva delle
competenze aveva delle conoscenze
pertanto è stato difficile ma facile a
partire cioè ci dobbiamo rendere conto
che la luce è un bene prezioso
forse senza renderci conto è il bene più
importante che abbiamo perché senza luce
noi ci sarebbe questa vita sociale
questa visita generale nel mondo stesso
non crescerebbero le piante non
noi non so se ci saremmo stati come ci
sono stati con quali supporti con quali
mezzi e l'altra parte importante è che
non abbiamo mai considerato quanto la
luce naturale in c.da fortemente a
secondo le latitudini alle quali noi
viviamo sulla nostra sul nostro stato
d'animo sui nostri stati emotivi sulle
nostre emozioni
e allora di giorno viviamo allegramente
che noi siamo fortunati a vivere in
italia pertanto abbiamo solo e ombre e
quanto serve per poter godere di queste
meraviglie locali ma se noi andassimo a
vivere in finlandia avremmo degli altri
problemi perché gli inverni sono
abbastanza lunghi con poca luce allora
se la luce è un bene primario
io grazie al alla slice avevano passato
prima che questa questo il vero e
prezioso teniamo lo gestiamo lo
dopodiché cercando di capire il sistema
complessivo della luce abbiamo anche
fatto degli studi per capire quanta luce
all'epoca 1982 92 assorbiva veniva
assorbita ma senza produrre l'efficienza
del servizio soprattutto nella
dimensione degli esterni i vecchi
prodotti colei che tecniche consumava il
70 per cento in più di quello che poteva
consumare un nuovo prodotto con le nuove
tecnologie con l'elettronica una lampada
scarica pertanto quanta luce consumiamo
una parte di questa come vedete era
sopra alle città che vedevamo da lontano
che si disperdeva verso il cielo
pertanto senza luce non ci sarebbe stata
in queste grandi metropoli
tra le altre cose non ci sarebbe stato
forse neanche lo sviluppo industriale in
inghilterra e allora cosa dobbiamo fare
per cercare di trovare un equilibrio
dobbiamo studiare
qual è la relazione esatta tra l'uomo la
luce e l'ambiente ci siamo agganciati a
una a una via un percorso di
investimento nella ricerca per capire
che illuminare una città a cui prima
facevo riferimento noi possiamo dare
questa attrazione questa bellezza a
creare pertanto attrazione turistica
attrazione culturale e dare benessere a
coloro che abitano
questi spazi l'altro è che lavorando di
giorno in ambienti privi di luce
naturale pertanto nella grande
distribuzione grandi magazzini agli
stabilimenti nelle fabbriche nelle nelle
strutture in cui la luce naturale a non
entrava sufficientemente perdevamo si
dice l'orologio del tempo e pertanto
andavamo nel tempo più o meno no in
stanchezza dopo le prime ore del mattino
dalla mia stanchezza nel pomeriggio
pertanto che cosa si doveva fare a
secondi lavori che si facevano che
facevamo per far sì che la gente
entrasse al lavoro sveglia motivata
entusiasta per poi avere
un'illuminazione che gestisse durante
l'arco della giornata soprattutto la
sera con una luce più calda anziché una
luce azzurra un momento di rilassamento
e pertanto di preparazione poi uscendo a
riposo pertanto tornando a casa avere
una sensazione è una motivazione in più
per vivere con queste consapevolezze a
friburgo e 50 fecero questo esperimento
sé i semi di zucca in vasetti di vetro
sotto luci diverse come quantità di
illuminazione come qualità cromatica
della luce ogni seme è cresciuto come
vedete sono stessi semi chi quale più
alta quelle più bassa
quella è più larga o più stretta allora
se la luce in follia così sui semi di
zucca pensate quanto poteva influire
sulla sulla psiche e sulla psicologia
dell'uomo e noi in quel periodo per
rafforzare questi concetti
lanciamo il progetto poligoni contro
l'inquinamento luminoso per due motivi 1
per pelle la dispersione che c'era nei
confronti no delle città illuminate
sopra l'altra chiaramente era perché
dovevamo risparmiare ma dobbiamo anche
capire come consumando lo stesso la
stessa energia elettrica riuscissimo a
dare maggiore benessere in tutti quegli
ambienti a cui erano confinati alla luce
naturale
voi pensate che questi sono parsi no che
sì chi sono i finlandesi che d'inverno
avendo no giornate brevi
cerco di vivere in un modo possibile
mettendoci alla luce sopra la testa per
creare no e combattere quello stato
depressivo che praticamente a cui vanno
incontro
e questo è un po il problema
dell'orologio del tempo i siti ciclici
card jani il cervello controlla tutto
controlla addirittura in base alla luce
azzurra o alla luce calda e quando il
fegato deve iniziare a lavorare e per
quanto tempo solo per dire quanto è
complesso questo sistema però i nostri
ricercatori e non noi soltanto gli
scienziati perché abbiamo lavorato con
l'università di troy negli stati uniti
per sviluppare questo primo apparecchio
di luce biodinamica e il primo nel 1993
che poi ha dato la vita a tutta una
serie di sperimentazioni e delle
applicazioni che oggi consente veramente
di dare risposte a tante esigenze non
solo di qualità della vita dell'ambiente
in cui c'era ora ma addirittura
percolare per curare il coma persone che
vanno in coma
schumacher mentre in cui c'è risveglio
lindsay esserci risveglio ma anche no
ancora in vita vegetativa anche la luce
di questo sistema biodinamico aiuta li
vedete aiuta perché la luce passa
attraverso la pelle viene assorbita dal
corpo come d'altronde tutti gli altri
fenomeni aspetti la voce della famiglia
la musica 9 e tante altre cose naturali
che per la quale l'uomo ha vissuto
questa è la scansione vedete che noi
senza accordi ci abbiamo la luce azzurra
dalla mattina fino alle prime ore del
pomeriggio per poi passare a quella
rosata ecco quella rosata
sostanzialmente è quella che inizia a
creare la melatonina la melatonina la
grande rapine a per consentire di poter
riposare a lungo e in maniera
confortevole
questi sono le applicazioni sperimentali
fatte in diversi centri centri di
e della della virgin per esempio del col
della vergine della tecnimont e
dell'aeroporto di madrid dove
praticamente questa gestione del flusso
luminoso consentiva questo tipo di
benessere questa è l'esperienza la
ricerca fatta all'ospedale maggiore di
bologna per gli amici di luca è stato
seguendo questo tipo di progetto e di
ricerca non si è riusciti ancora a
capire dal 2001 quanto la luce azzurra
perché è la luce azzurra che crea questo
tipo di benessere che risveglia la
persona e la stimola verso no la vita e
pertanto anche verso il lavoro no più
attivo e non si sa quanto vale la
qualità e la quantità della luce
necessaria per arrivare a a dare
veramente diritti mia secondo il
soggetto su cui si deve intervenire la
luce emozione
qui siamo all'aurora boreale quale
vedete fotograficamente quelli che sono
gli effetti che si possono creare che
sono veri comunque o la luce e potenza
la luce è una guida un orientamento è
una sicurezza la luce anche un gioco
ovviamente ma attenzione che il buio
favore senza luce
quando si vive soprattutto per i bambini
ma anche per professione grandi questo è
un senso di fortuna come la luce celebra
una festa rende e festoso grande allegri
la luce spesso anche un mistero
quando ci troviamo in ambienti in cui si
è incerto in una situazione di
illuminazione che è sufficiente non è
sufficiente abbagliante diventa
eccessiva addirittura o oppure come
succede quando si torna a casa e
l'intimità
ecco allora
la luce e l'atmosfera della festa e la
luce ancora l'axel qual è il sogno che
noi abbiamo ancora è quello di aver
lavorato a livello mondiale in tutti i
settori nei più grandi musei del mondo
nei più grandi grattacieli del mondo o
alberghi del mondo a sette stelle o con
le più belle marche nei settori
dell'automobile della moda ma abbiamo
ancora un sogno da realizzare che è
quello di illuminare l'altra faccia
della luna e ci auguriamo di farcela e
l'altro invito che noi facciamo
diamoci una botta di luce azzurra forte
per svegliare il nostro paese che faccia
bene ai nostri politici che faccia bene
la nostra classe dirigente perché noi
abbiamo bisogno di ritornare a vincere
nella competizione internazionale grazie